naraditsky after the
the finals yesterday we got ourselves a
rematch
last game of the day for all the marbles
in the world
so we're gonna play a nice slow
italian
and
so something good i did against me just
transferring the night before before
everything
should have gone bishop b3 i should have
gone bishop b3
not to allow this i was a bit silly
we'll take it we go d4 and we'll see
now i guess we go h3
and then bishop e3
after having prevented uh knight to
g4 queen g6 i'm happy to meet with
knight h4
and d5 then i go e5
and then think
i think in principle i'm not too opposed
to
the exchange in g3 after fg3 i do have
a double pawn but
i do also have some possibilities of
attacking with
um with g4 there later on
and some better king safety
so now i think i'll go queen g4 he may
have made a mistake here
made a mistake
thing is i'm threatening to take an e6
and also knight g6 is a serious
positional
positional idea here i think probably he
needed to go
um he needed just to
to go for something else there maybe to
go king f7
strange as it looks
now i think i'm doing just great i'll
take
i'll even just take on c6
and i have so much positional
compensation for the exchange
i think maybe even b4
[Music]
maybe that's trying to be too clever but
i want to try and be too clever
just shutting the bishop on on a7 out of
the game
also the queen on on h7 is a sorry sight
at the moment
rook f5 is a good it's a good try though
i didn't see that
did not see that
okay we shamefully retreat tonight
still i think with very good
compensation
and then queen to e2
now i have to look out for the threat
which is bishop takes d4
so we go queen c4
now i have to play faster
h2 soon we're going to be collecting
g3 now we start
go back
that's annoying move let's take the pawn
we attack this one
now i certainly have a winning position
and the question is can i convert it in
time
[Music]
i'm hoping of course the answer will be
yes
and i think it will be as well a5 now
i'm i'm gonna win the piece and have a
very safe position
okay f2 next f7 take
and he mouse slipped there he's gonna
take a beat
but i have more than enough time
okay people